- From the very beginning,
I got an email from someone
that knows the Cuomo
family very well
that said to me, you know,
"I'm sorry for your loss.",
something we never heard from
the Governor, by the way.
"I'm sorry for your loss,
your fight is a valiant
one, but watch your back."
(suspenseful music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
joining me today
is the senior
meteorologist at Fox News,
author of the new book,
Make Your Own Sunshine:
Inspiring stories of
people who find a light
in dark times,
and a woman who is not a
big fan of New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo, Janice
Dean, finally.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Oh my gosh.
Thank you for having
me, my friend.
- How'd you like that
little addition that I gave
to your bio there, did that,
does that feel right to you?
- You know, I gotta tell you,
if you told me a year ago
that I would be in
the middle of a storm
involving the
Governor of New York
I would have said,
"What are you drinking?
"And where can I get some?"
- Well, you certainly are.
And you know, my audience knows
I try to do these
interviews really
as free form as possible.
But I thought with
this interview,
I'm gonna do it a little
more intentionally,
because the book which
I've been reading
over the last couple
of days, it's so light,
and warm and decent, and it
puts a smile on your face.
But this last year, you really
have stepped into a fight
that so many of us
are dealing with it
at so many different levels.
So for people that have no
idea about what has gone on
in your life in the past
year, can you just lay it out,
how did this all start,
and when did you
decide to really get
into the public fight?
- March 25th was the order
which Governor Cuomo
put his signature on
that allowed
COVID-positive patients
into nursing homes,
9,000 of them.
And that was a fairly
recent development.
The reason why I'm so interested
in this topic is because
we lost my husband's parents
in separate elder
care facilities,
in late March, we lost his dad,
and in April, about two weeks
later, we lost his mother,
and obviously tragic,
I never planned to be
someone who is a spokesperson
on behalf of no, my
husband's parents,
and thousands of
others that we lost,
but I felt like I had to,
because when I saw the
Governor on television programs
like his brother's
on CNN joking around,
and not even approaching
the nursing home issue,
that's when I decided to
get a little bit angry,
because I felt like my husband's
parents and the situation
that they were presented
with, unknowingly,
was not being represented
fairly in the mainstream media.
And, you know, going
back to his parents,
we didn't even know there
was a March 25th order.
And the plan was,
we were supposed to
have both of them at
an assisted living residence
close to us on Long Island.
I feel, you know,
kindred spirits
with people who
have to talk about
what to do with
their aging parents.
Their health was failing them,
they lived in a four-story walk
up in Brooklyn for 50 years,
we had many conversations
about getting them out of there
because they were going to
have issues trying to go up
and down the stairs,
so for many years, the
conversation was there,
we wanted to get them
into a different place,
we offered to help
them monetarily,
and they just never
wanted to take that.
They just said, "We're
just gonna stick it out,
"we love it here,
"and we'll deal with
it as it comes."
And as it happened,
his dad got dementia,
his health was failing him,
his mom was very spry for,
you know, a 75, 76 year old,
but she had back problems,
she had problems walking,
and so it got to the point
where we had aids
going to visit them,
that wasn't working out,
so we took his mom to look
at assisted facilities,
and she loved the one
close to us on Long Island.
She signed the paperwork.
His father was in bad health,
so we had to get
him in better shape
before he could
he could join her
in the assisted
living residence,
and that's when COVID happened.
I mean, we hadn't even
cleared out their apartment,
we were still paying
the rent for them,
so it was very recent
that we had put them in
the elder care facilities,
they had never been
separated in their lives,
and we were just hoping
to get Mickey, his father,
in better shape.
So COVID happened, we were
in quarantine in early March,
we weren't able to see them,
we were getting updates
from their separate
elder care facilities,
Sean was able to talk
to his mom every day,
because she was, you
know, she was lucid,
his dad, obviously, it was
tough because he had dementia.
We got a call on a Saturday
morning in late March,
not even knowing he was ill,
and they said that Mickey
was not feeling well,
and he was running a fever.
And so of course
we were concerned,
and we were talking about
what we were gonna do,
and three hours later, we get
a call saying he was dead.
We had no idea he
had died of COVID
until we saw the
death certificate,
and Sean had to deliver
the news to his mother,
and to say that she
was heartbroken is
an understatement.
She got sick in her
assisted living facility,
was diagnosed with COVID
when they brought her
to the hospital and she
died in the hospital,
several days later.
The last thing she asked my
husband to do was put her name
on the Easter
gifts for the kids.
So I never wanted
to tell their story,
my husband is a
very private person.
He's not on TV, he's
not a broadcaster.
He's a firefighter, 25
years in the department.
His dad was a
firefighter, as well.
But when I wasn't
seeing the coverage
of the nursing home issue,
and the fact that
I was finding out
that Cuomo wasn't counting
those that died in the hospital
like my mother-in-law,
that's when I
decided it was time
to tell my story, our story,
so that at least somebody,
anybody would, you know,
find out that this
was actually something
that was happening in New York.
- Yeah, boy, all right.
There's so many sort of off
shoots where we go there,
first off, I have to say, I
don't know if you know this,
but I'm actually from
Long Island as well,
and I know a lot of Long
Island firefighters,
so I have no doubt that
Sean is a great guy,
'cause every single
one of them that I know
are great people.
Well, I guess first, just for
a little more on the timeline,
so how long was it that your
folks didn't see each other,
or your in-laws
didn't see each other
before you got that call
about your father-in-law?
- Well, you know,
it started out that
both Mickey and Dee were in
the nursing home together,
but his mother was
in better shape,
so that's when she went to
the assisted living residence,
and I would say they were
probably apart for a few weeks.
So they were apart
for a few weeks,
but they knew that they would
be together at some point
at the assisted
living residence.
So, you know, it
wasn't very long
that COVID happened when
they were in this situation.
- Do you remember
when Cuomo signed
that piece of legislation
or whatever it was,
do you remember thinking,
uh-oh, this could be a problem?
There were so many
things happening at once,
it was almost like
impossible to make sense
of any of it back then.
I know it's hard to
remember just a year ago.
- We didn't know about it, Dave.
I mean, honestly I found out
about it after they had died.
No one told us about it.
You know, I remember
the red flag
after the fact was that we
got a call about Mickey,
I would say about a week
before he passed away
saying that they were gonna
move him to another floor,
because they were going
to allow for more people
to come into the residence,
but they didn't say
infected patients,
and we had no idea.
We only learned
after they had died
that there was a
mandate in place
to put COVID-positive patients.
So, you know, that's a big deal.
I think whose responsibility
would that have been,
the nursing home, the
assisted living residence?
Someone should have told us.
But the other point of that
is that we weren't
able to see them.
You know, we were in quarantine,
Sean did see his mom
before she got sick.
He dropped off
flowers and a card
after his dad had passed away,
and he was able to see her
six feet away with a mask on,
but he wasn't able to go
and hug her, you know,
so there were all
these things in place
where we physically
couldn't do anything,
you were almost jailed.
You know, you couldn't move,
you couldn't find things out,
you couldn't go see them,
you couldn't bring them to you.
You know, obviously if I had
known about a March 25th order,
we would have done
things very differently,
we would have found a
way to bring them here,
you know, his sister-in-law
would have taken one of them,
we would have done something.
- Yeah, look, we all
know hindsight is 2020,
but do you think in retrospect
that the nursing
homes themselves
should have done
different things,
should have just
protested the order?
I mean, do you think that they,
some of them may
have sort of known,
I know that we
have more info now,
so I know it's tough to do
that kind of quarterbacking.
- From what I know, and the
people that I've talked with
that work in nursing homes,
they did not want to take
the COVID-positive patients.
They felt they had no choice,
and if you read the order,
they weren't allowed
to even test them.
They were prohibited from
testing them for COVID.
So, you know, that
in itself is like
if you couldn't test them,
then you didn't know if
they even had the virus.
So I think --
- What could be the logic
behind not being
allowed to test people,
that you're bringing
into the home?
- Well, this is a
bigger, broader subject
that I think we
need to investigate.
There are several investigations
into the nursing home issue,
which I am grateful for.
There's a federal one,
and there's an FBI one.
And what I wanna
know is first of all,
the origins of the
March 25th order,
where did that come from?
Because it's not
based on science.
We all knew that putting
infected patients
into where our most vulnerable
live is not scientific.
It was going to
spread like wildfire,
which is what our
Governor said, as well,
that it would be like
wildfire through dry grass.
So I wanna know where
that order came from.
There are reports out there
that the governor was
not listening to science,
he was listening to
hospital lobbyists,
who were saying to him,
- Right.
"We can't take these
patients for very long.
"You know, they're not
maybe paying customers.
"We need to get them
over to someplace else
"so that we can allow for
more people to come in."
At the beginning of the
pandemic, he had no idea.
We thought it was gonna be
thousands upon thousands
of people that
were going to come
into the hospitals and
take over the beds.
So at the beginning,
I don't blame him
for not really knowing
what to do and sort of say,
"Well maybe we should
put them the back end.",
but it was in place for 46 days.
And then it was reversed and
scrubbed from the website.
So that should also
tell you something.
I think there is
corruption involved,
I think there is a
criminal aspect to it,
I think it involves
hospital lobbyists,
and the curious thing
as well is that Cuomo
put it in place for
a blanket immunity
for all of the nursing homes,
so that we could not sue them,
just a couple of days
after that March 25th order
was put into effect.
- Have you talked to lawyers
about how that could
possibly be legal?
'Cause when I was doing
a little research,
that seems crazy that
the Governor in effect
is allowed to say, "I'm
going to make a policy.
"And regardless of the
results of the policy
"I'm going to make
sure that the places
"that I'm forcing to do
something cannot be sued."
I mean, I don't even see how
that could be remotely legal.
- Well, they're trying now
in Albany to reverse that,
that executive order, so
that the nursing homes
can be held accountable.
Listen, it's not
about suing people --
- Do you want them to
be held accountable?
I mean, is that with, yeah.
- I'll never get my
in-laws back, right?
And the nursing homes,
I felt like they were
just doing what they could
with the situation
that they had.
They were wearing garbage bags.
They had no PPE.
That's another separate issue is
they didn't have the wherewithal
to deal with all of these
patients that were coming in,
and you listen,
they took good care of my
husband's parents, you know,
before COVID, so, and we're
not getting any answers
from them either, I
think they're afraid,
I know that the nursing
home people, the executives
and the folks that work
in the nursing homes,
they are afraid to talk.
They don't wanna
lose their jobs.
And I do think that there needs
to be more whistleblowers.
And that's why I think
there needs to be
a real investigation
with subpoena power,
so people in the
nursing home industry
and the hospital industry,
those that really
wanna tell the truth,
they can come forward
without thinking
that they're gonna
lose their livelihoods.
- So when did you decide to
really go public about this?
'Cause as you said, your
husband's a private person,
and although you're a
public person, you know,
it's his parents,
they're your in-laws,
it's not something that it
would be that comfortable
talking about probably
'cause it's deeply personal,
all that kinda stuff.
- Well, when I started
to see the information
about the March 25th order,
and then I started to
see the information,
the Daily Caller was the
one that put out a report
saying that Cuomo
wasn't counting those
that died in the hospital.
And I thought that that was
bizarre, because it's like,
if there's a car
crash on the highway,
and the person doesn't,
unfortunately, you know,
tragically die on the highway,
but they're transported
to the hospital,
does that mean that's
a hospital death?
No, of course not.
It's still a car crash that
happened on the highway.
So that to me was curious,
and I started seeing
the governor going on
all of these television
programs and talking about,
you know, how great
his leadership was,
New York tough, you
know, bending that curve.
He was selling a poster.
He was selling a poster
showing that bend of the curve,
which was like a mountain,
and had all the COVID cases.
And I thought to
myself, how gross
that he's using COVID
cases, my husband's parents
are on that curve that
he supposedly crushed.
And then on the poster,
there was all these
like little pictures
of the things that he
loved about himself,
like it's his dog
and a giant q-tip,
because of the, you know, the
show that he was putting on
with his brother, Chris
Cuomo on television.
That was the breaking
point for me.
I was thinking about
writing an op-ed
about the situation
because it was,
I thought I wanted to
tell my family story
to bring awareness.
But when I saw Cuomo on with
his brother joking around,
like, who's the favorite
son and love gov,
and the big giant
q-tip, I lost my mind.
I just thought to myself,
this is, what kind of
universe am I living in,
with thousands upon
thousands of dead,
the body bags are piling up
outside of nursing homes.
We weren't able to
have wakes or funerals.
We were, we luckily we knew
someone who owned a funeral home
who went to school
with my sister-in-law,
that helped us bury them,
so that's when I decided
to talk to my friend,
Tucker Carlson, I was
telling him what was going on
with the nursing
homes and my concerns
with what was
happening in New York.
And he told me, he said,
"You have an invitation
to come on my show,
"if you ever wanna
tell the story."
And so it was that
day after I saw
the Cuomo Brothers comedy hour
that I went on Tucker Show.
- That, I mean, okay.
So everyone remembers
that interview with Chris
and Governor Cuomo and you
know, the laughing and all that.
So I'm gonna jump forward
for just a second.
But when you saw Chris
'cause I'm sure you
saw it a few weeks ago
say that he can no longer talk
about his brother on the show
because it's personal.
I mean, that's like basically
vomit-inducing stuff.
Like we can give him the worst
sort of fluff interviews,
we can both sit there
with our fake tans,
and laugh hysterically and have
everyone write fluff pieces
about the sexy Cuomo
brothers or whatever it is
that they're doing on HuffPo.
And then, and now, oh, now
he's in a little hot water.
Wouldn't be journalistic
if I talked about him now.
- Right.
Can you imagine if that
happened on Fox News?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Right, so I don't even
think Chris Cuomo should be
on television right now.
It's not ethical.
I mean, Cuomo was a
huge story, right?
I mean, the guy
could be impeached.
There are, you know
motions going forward
that he could be impeached.
We have Me Too involved
now with eight women,
he doesn't even do
like a news segment,
you know, he just
continues to do his show,
ignoring the huge
elephant in the room.
So yeah, it's quite
rich for him to say
that he can no longer
interview his brother.
It blows me.
- Yeah, so then,
then the story blows up
and now you now you sort of
became the center of this
thing for a couple of weeks.
It was like, oh, the
nursing home thing,
people couldn't believe it,
you're right in
the center of it.
Since I spent so much
time in this show
talking about cancel
culture and dealing
with the mob and
everything else,
can you just talk about,
a little bit about like
the love and I'm
guessing some of the hate
that you've received in
the midst of all this?
- From the very beginning,
I got an email from someone
that knows the Cuomo
family very well
that said to me, you know,
"I'm sorry for your loss.",
something we never heard from
the Governor, by the way,
"I'm sorry for your loss.
"Your fight is a valiant
one, but watch your back."
- Right, yeah.
- I knew that early on that
I was in for the fight,
and I had heard that
he was vindictive,
I also heard that
he was a bully,
you know, there were many times
that I would do interviews
and they would always
ask the Governor's office
to make a comment,
and twice the Governor's
office said, "Well, you know,
"can you ask Jan
--" first of all,
they never said we're
really sorry for your loss.
It was always,
"Can you ask Janice the
exact day her in-laws died
"and what nursing
homes they were at?"
So twice the Governor's
office asked that.
And then there was
one time there was
a Daily Mail article
that was put out
and they asked for a
comment and the quote was
"She's not a reliable
source on anything
"except the weather."
So, you know, and I
just thought to myself,
well you know, that's not
very creative (laughs),
but certainly on social media
in the early days of this,
I was, you know, I was
definitely attacked.
He was the most powerful guy,
I mean, they were talking
about him being the President.
He was, you know, the fact
that he was writing a book
in the middle of the pandemic,
and then again,
being on television,
celebrating himself
winning an Emmy Award.
And he had all these celebrities
that were appearing with him
at his press conferences.
I actually got into a
little bit of a Twitter spat
with Ben Stiller,
because he was doing
a birthday celebration
with Whoopi
Goldberg, by the way,
they raised money for Cuomo --
- How much was it per plate,
it for a virtual event.
It was like 20 grand a
plate for a virtual event
in the midst of all
of this, something --
- Right, it was at least
$1,000 for the bare minimum.
So I just thought, listen,
I'm gonna let Ben Stiller know
what happened to the
nursing homes in New York.
He's a New Yorker.
And he came back at
me pretty quickly
and was just like, "Well,
I like the Governor.
"It's too bad that
you don't like him."
And you know, it was
just so dismissive,
and it didn't take long
for Ben Stiller to realize,
you know, what my
family had been through,
and to his credit --
- Oh good.
which is more than
most people do,
he apologized and he
deleted his tweet.
And I actually said,
I'm okay with that.
You know, he didn't
know my family story.
Now he does.
Maybe he's more educated
on the situation.
And that's my whole thing is
if one person can be educated
by me telling my story about
what's happening in New York,
then all of that is worthwhile.
- So what do you make of
sort of where Cuomo
is at right now?
Because you know, now
he's got, as you said,
there's at least eight
women accusing him
of some level of
sexual impropriety,
I mean, I've said this
a million times before,
it's like, okay, an
accusation is one thing,
but of course you need proof,
you need corroboration,
but that's not the rules that
his team have been playing by
for quite some time.
Those weren't the rules
with Brett Kavanaugh
or a litany of other
people on the right.
So this is sort of his making.
Just where do you sense he's
at right now between that,
and of course, all of this?
- Well, he's not going to leave.
He's already said that.
And there is, you know, I
think it's kind of a sham.
They say that they've
started the proceedings
for impeachment in New
York, but it's going to
take not weeks but months and
then they're done in June.
So I don't think
that's going to happen.
I am relying on the law.
You know, the investigations
that are going on right now
the Federal investigation,
the FBI investigation,
there was also a
DOJ investigation,
you know, under bar that I
hope continues under Biden.
The Me Too stuff, at first,
I was a little
bit shocked by it,
but now that I think of the
person that we're talking about
you know, sexual harassment
is not about sex.
It's about power.
And so his whole MO is about
"I'm the most powerful guy
and I can do whatever I want."
So now it doesn't surprise me
that he treated women badly
and he's treated
other people badly.
You know, his
coworkers, Ron Kim,
who is a friend of
mine, he is a Democrat.
He had an uncle that
died in a nursing home.
He's been very vocal about
the nursing home situation.
I am grateful for him because
he is raising awareness
on his side of the
aisle of the situation.
And he also came out
with his experience
with the Governor,
calling him on a weekend,
yelling at him and
saying, you know,
"I'm gonna ruin you essentially,
if you go against me."
So I just, I hope
and pray, Dave,
that the law helps us out here,
and that they get to the
bottom and he, you know,
the truth, the whole truth
and nothing but the truth,
I've always said, the only
thing I want right now
is a bipartisan investigation
with subpoena power
that puts the Governor
on the stand so to speak,
his health commissioner,
Howard Zucker,
and the people that surrounded
him that helped cover
up the numbers.
You know, that's another
big story is the fact
that it was the AG, the
democratic AG here in New York,
put out her own report saying
that they purposely
under-counted the
nursing home deaths.
Those that died in the
hospital were never counted.
- I mean, listen,
as a New Yorker,
I know how out of whack the
whole state government is
in New York and half the people
that were in it 10 years ago
are in jail right now.
It's all very
bizarre in New York.
Has this changed any of
your political beliefs
as you've been in this fight?
- You know, I've always said
I'm not a political person,
I never have been, I'm
originally from Canada (laughs).
You know, I was
born in Canada --
- I think there's a
government up there, right?
You got a government, that
guy with the fancy socks.
- Yes, the fancy socks guy,
you know my Mom is more
political than I am.
You should meet her sometime.
But you know, I'm the
meteorologist on Fox.
I've always said the only
red and blue that I see
on the map are areas of low
pressure and high pressure.
And I stick with that.
I like the fact that nobody
knows who I voted for,
when I got the job at Fox,
it was never a prerequisite
to tell them who I voted for.
So I will remain that way.
But I will tell you,
I've often said to people
"What if I worked for
a different channel
"and the Governor that I was
going after was a Republican.
"What do you think would happen
"and how much coverage do you
think my story would get?"
- Yeah, I get what
you're dropping.
I get what you're dropping.
All right, well, before
we move on from this,
because I do wanna talk
about the book, of course,
I mean, is there anything else?
Well, actually wait, I do
have one other thing for sure,
which is that we actually
delayed this interview taping
a few days because you just
got the second COVID shot,
and it sounds like that thing
really knocked you out, huh?
- Oh, listen.
I am pro-vaccine I have MS,
I was diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis 16 years ago,
so I'm a compromised person.
And so I believe
in vaccinations,
and I was always
wanting to get one.
And so my neurologist wrote
me a note and I was, you know,
I was in line with the
other comorbidities.
The first shot was fine.
You know, I had the
pain in the arm,
and then the second shot,
my husband also had had
the vaccinations as well.
And he didn't do too badly.
You know, for maybe 12 to
18 hours, he was flu-ish,
and, you know, he had
the aches and pains,
but man, I, you know, for,
I would say for 48 hours,
it was like I had COVID, and
I had the worst headache.
The headache was so bad that
I was nauseous the whole time.
And you know, I couldn't
see my children,
I couldn't look at anything,
I couldn't see the TV,
I was literally in a dark room.
So, you know,
listen, I'm grateful.
I've come out of it on the
other side, doing well.
And I encourage everyone
to get the vaccine,
I believe in vaccinations,
and I'm grateful for
the scientists that
came up with them,
but yes, I will warn those,
the second vaccination
can be a doozy.
- Well, that is
the perfect segue,
because you're saying all of
that, while you're smiling.
And that really is,
that really is the point
of the book and excellent
product placement behind you,
by the way --
- (laughs) Thank you.
- Really, really spot on.
- But one of the things --
- You too.
- Oh well, you know,
I've got people,
but one of the things that I
really loved about the book is
when I do my show every day,
I try to do it with a little
bit of a smile on my face.
I try to do it so that
people don't feel depressed
after about the news.
I'm not trying to just
bludge in everybody
so that they're stuck watching,
which is pretty much what CNN
and a lot of the other
places are doing.
So I guess first, how
did you kind of come
to that place where telling
people some of the good stuff
actually mattered to you?
- I've been telling good news
stories for many years now.
I do a feature on Fox News
Radio called the Dean's List.
And it's a 60-second,
feel-good story
about a person doing kind
things for someone else,
or, you know doing
something that brings
sunshine into someone's day.
So I've been doing that
for a very long time.
And I always thought to myself,
I would love to make
this into a book
where I could dive into
these stories each,
make them a chapter.
So this was that book.
I started working on
it before the pandemic,
but I wrote most of it,
and did a lot of the
interviews during the pandemic.
And more than ever,
even though we were socially
distancing from each other,
I was finding these
stories all over the place
of people doing wonderful
things for other people,
we were adapting
as human beings,
you know, you saw people doing
car parades for birthdays.
I got one of those.
My husband did that for
me, for my 50th birthday.
So, and the other part
of this was, you know,
I wanted to put this
book out in the universe
for other people to read,
to show them that there are
good people doing kind things
for others all over the place.
It's what unites us.
You know, I really think that
kindness begets kindness,
and those that do good
things for others,
it gets passed along, right?
So, but what I didn't
realize Dave is that
I was the one that was
going to get the most
out of writing this book
because I was talking
to these wonderful people
during the darkest time
for our family,
and getting light and goodness
from all of these stories and
interviews that I was doing,
and every day, you know,
I'd take my oldest son,
Matthew for a walk.
And that would be our
topic of conversation.
He'd be like, "Mom
who'd you talk to today,
"tell me the story."
And I would tell him the
story of the napkin notes,
Dad who wrote napkin notes
for his daughter, Emma,
when she was just a little girl,
and how he continued doing that,
even though he was
diagnosed with cancer,
and thought he might not
live to see her graduate.
So he wanted to make sure
he wrote napkin notes
for hundreds of school
days in case they lost him.
He's still here,
and I talked to him
and I talked to Emma,
and so those are the people
that brightened my day,
when we were going
through such dark times.
So that's the ironic
part of this is
I got so much out of
writing this book,
more so than I ever
thought I would.
- Yeah, so I wanna dive into
a couple of the stories,
'cause there's some really
great stuff in there,
but I'm curious when you
were pitching the book,
and bringing it to your
publishers and everything,
is selling a book
that's so positive,
is that tough for those guys?
'Cause if you just
look at a bookstore
you know, front area,
what's in the window,
I mean, it's all basically
depressing stuff.
You know, the world's
coming to end,
the pandemic's gonna kill you,
Trump tried to kill you,
and somebody else's
coming to get ya,
you know, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
- It's a tough sell,
I'm not gonna lie.
And what I didn't tell you is,
before the Dean's List happened,
I did a good news
story on Fox News,
a show called Happening Now
with my friend Jane Skinner.
And she was the one that
came up with the Dean's List,
because she thought, you
know, the news is so terrible,
we need something
bright and cheery,
and you do the weather and
you know, the weather is
a lot of times
it's mostly sunny,
but sometimes it's stormy,
but why don't we work
on a good news story
that we can use as a kicker,
we call it a kicker
in the business.
And so we started doing
that on television,
but the news kind
of like took over
and the Dean's List got
killed more often than not,
but I was, you know, she was
always a cheerleader of it.
So the moral of the
story is, you know what?
Sometimes the good
news doesn't sell,
but I think now more than ever,
we need these stories, Dave,
you know, I really think
that we need to hear
these hopeful good
stories about trying to be
a better human being.
And so that's my message.
And I will tell you (laughs)
that I got a lot of
people saying to me,
"Okay, your book is coming out.
"When are you gonna stop
with the Cuomo stuff?
"Because we need the bright
(microphone cuts out)"
so it'd be like,
"I am the sunny
girl who brought you
"this the most to make
your own sunshine stories."
And I said, "You know what?
"I'm both.
"Why can't I be both?"
Because I am both.
I am still the
glass is half full.
I'm still the mostly sunny girl.
I'm also an advocate
who wants to shine
sunlight as a disinfectant.
So, you know,
I think the advocacy can also
be making your own sunshine.
So, you know, trying to
balance both of those things
is I can be both
at the same time,
but I'm not gonna lie.
Sometimes the good news
stories are a tough sell.
- Excellent use of the
metaphor with sunshine
as the best disinfectant that
fully works with the book.
Give me like two
stories that you,
that really
particularly moved you.
I can pick one or two,
but if you got some
that are right off
the top of your head?
- Well, it's funny,
because everyone tells me a
different story that they love.
And that's what I love
about it is that, you know,
someone will say, "Well,
I loved, you know,
"the Carrie Blazey story."
So I'll tell you that one.
That was the first one,
one of the first interviews
that I did during the pandemic,
and Carrie and I became very
close friends, afterwards.
Simple story.
Her daughter was diagnosed
with type one diabetes,
forgive me type two diabetes,
what's the more serious one?
Forgive me.
I don't wanna screw this up,
so I'm gonna get
my book right now.
- This is impressive.
An author actually
going to the source.
I like it.
- Well it's interesting --
- Wait, I've got,
let's see who can find it first?
- I don't wanna screw it
up because there's this
really, okay, there's
two types of diabetes,
and the one that she has
is the really serious one,
type one.
- Type one, okay.
And that's why it's important,
because Carrie is a big
advocate for type one diabetes,
because that's, you know,
not to say that type two
is not a serious
illness as well,
but type one is when
you're really really
constantly concerned
about your child,
every day they take her,
you know her measurements
or glucose levels.
She's got a special, you know,
a special portal on her body
that has to be, you know,
her insulin has to be just
right, the right level.
So having said that, Carrie
put a sign on her door saying
that she had a person
who was compromised
living in her house.
And as a person
who lives with MS,
I can totally
identify with that.
At the beginning
of the pandemic,
we didn't know how bad it was.
She didn't want the virus
anywhere near her daughter,
her compromised daughter,
so she put a sign on
the door that said
"If you have any deliveries,
leave the package here.
"Don't ring my doorbell.
"I'm not opening up the
door, just leave it here,
"and I will sanitize the
package and bring it in."
So a wonderful FedEx driver
sees the sign and says,
"Oh", goes back to
his FedEx truck,
they see this, by
the way, on a camera,
he doesn't know that
he's being filmed.
They have one of those nest
cameras on their doorstep.
He goes back to the FedEx truck,
grabs some wipes and
wipes the package.
He smudges the print
on the package,
and thinks to himself, "Oh
I don't want them to wonder
"why the package is smudged."
So he writes a note saying,
"I saw your note on the door.
"I sanitized the package,
have a great day."
He didn't expect
anything from that.
She saw the video of
this kind FedEx driver,
and thought to herself, "Wow.
"He went the extra mile,
"took the extra step to
do this for my family."
And her husband was
the one who said
"You should put that
out on social media.
"Maybe he'll get a raise
"or FedEx will do something
nice for this driver."
And she put it on social media.
It went viral.
FedEx certainly,
you know, saw that,
Justin Bradshaw, by the
way, is the FedEx driver.
And as it turns out,
Justin has a little girl
that when she was
born was a preemie,
and they had to
take care of her,
and they were worried about her.
So his backstory sort of
reflects upon, you know,
why he was doing
what he was doing.
So that's the story of Carrie
Blazey and her daughter, Emma,
and the wonderful
FedEx driver, Justin,
who did a kind thing that
deserves all of our attention,
and that's why I started
the book with that chapter.
- Yeah, and it's interesting
because it's like,
a sort of at face
value what he did
wasn't that extraordinary,
except I think what
people have realized
in this past year is that
it is these little things
that are becoming
sort of extraordinary
as we socially distance,
and we don't hug people anymore,
and you wear a mask, and
sunglasses, and a hat,
and then people don't
even see your face,
but these little things, was
that like a theme for you,
that little things have
somehow become bigger?
- Yes, so there are definitely
the little things in there,
like buying someone's coffee
in line and then doing it
for the next person and
someone buying a coffee
for you can change
someone's day.
It's that simple.
But I also talked
about bigger movements,
for instance my
husband's friend Ray,
well he was my friend too.
Ray Pfeifer, FDNY, he was there
after the Twin Towers fell.
- Yeah, this is the one
that I wanted to
ask you about, yeah.
- Digging for his friends
for months in toxic, a
toxic stew that we now know
was so bad that it caused
9/11-related illnesses.
Ray got very sick with cancer,
and he was just
one of those guys
that would walk into a room
and you just would gravitate,
we called him Ray of light.
We called him the mayor because
he would walk into a room
and you would
gravitate towards Ray,
he would do anything
for you, you know
shirt off his back kind of guy.
So he got sick with
9/11-related cancer,
because he dug for
months trying to find
his fellow firefighters
that you know,
their families wanted to
at least find some remains.
So he spent the rest of his
days after he was diagnosed
making sure that
other first responders
would never have to
worry about healthcare
if they were diagnosed like
him with 9/11-related illness.
So Ray screamed as
loud as he could,
he went to Capitol Hill,
he banged on Congress doors,
Chuck Schumer, you know, like,
"Listen, I'm dying of cancer.
"I wanna make sure my brothers
and sisters have healthcare
"so that their families
don't have to worry.",
because it's, you know,
their bills are high.
And so, you know, he's
no longer with us,
but I call, he was making
sunshine for his friends
and his fellow firefighters,
and his fellow first
responders like my husband.
I know that if my
husband ever got sick,
Ray would take care of him,
and he would take
care of our family.
So that was an important
story for me to tell,
and you know what?
When I think about
my fight right now
with the Governor, I
think of Ray Pfeifer,
because he did
everything he could
to raise awareness for good.
- You know, it's interesting,
because when I was reading
the story about Ray,
I was in New York
also during 9/11,
as I said, I'm from Long Island,
but I lived in Manhattan on
the Upper East during 9/11.
And I remember about
two weeks after 9/11,
when people finally started
even just leaving
their houses again,
'cause we were all
glued to the television,
and also the smell out
there and everything else.
I remember I was on
a basketball court.
I went to play basketball
by Gracie Mansion.
I was like, I've gotta
get out of the house.
I just like, I can't
stay in my house anymore.
And I was playing basketball
with just a couple of random
guys and somebody elbowed
one guy and they got
into each other's face,
and they were about
to hit each other,
like you could, I've seen
this a million times,
it was about to happen,
and they both started crying
at the exact same time.
Both started crying.
Like I'm getting chills up my
spine as I'm telling you this.
And so I was thinking about
that when I was reading this,
because it's like
those little moments
of humanity, that is
the important stuff,
and it's sort of like, we could
use a little more of that.
I hate to say it, but
that sort of post-9/11
like yeah, we all kind
of are in this together,
whether you like it or not.
- I agree, I hope
we can get there.
I don't know that
we can right now,
I feel like people are angry,
and they're rightfully
angry, Dave.
I mean, we've been
trapped in our homes,
it depends on where
you live, obviously,
but here in New York,
I mean people still can't
see their loved ones
in nursing homes,
people have lost
their businesses and
their livelihoods.
I mean, this is tough.
I hope we can get to a point
where we can, you know,
smile at each other again.
And, but having said that,
I do see those
pieces of humanity.
You know, what we went
through with our family,
I mean, from the
firefighter down the street
that brought us
a meal, you know,
just dropped it on our doorstep,
to all of the prayer cards
and prayers that we got
from other people, our
church, obviously, you know,
opened their arms,
there were parishes all
over New York that said
that they were gonna
honor my husband's family.
So it's there.
And like I say in the book,
sometimes you just have
to really look for it,
because if you're
not open to it,
and you don't open
your heart to it,
then it might not come to you,
so I think that maybe that's
what we have to do is,
we have to look for it.
- Yeah, so I don't want you
to give away the entire book
in this interview, but
can you give me one more
that maybe was like,
sort of unexpected,
or maybe it went in a direction
that you didn't think when
you sat down with someone,
something like that?
- You know, let's see,
that's a good one.
I'm gonna think about
that for a moment.
- You can go to the
source if you need it.
- I know, let me take a look.
You know, there's
so many of them.
- Well, actually,
while you're looking,
I'll mention something else.
So you can look for a second.
But one of the things
that I really liked
and I will hold the
book up for a second
is that I like that you
put the photos in here too,
because you don't see that
in books that much anymore.
It used to, I feel like photos
always used to be in books,
and you don't really
see it anymore.
But when you just see, these
are just regular people,
young girl, you know, the 9/11,
the, you know, just
guys on the street,
people with glamor
shots, you're like,
"Oh", it reminds you that, you
know, we're all just human.
That's all it is.
- It's true, I'm
glad you said that,
because I really fought
hard to make sure
that their pictures
were in the book.
You know how you read a book,
and you have a visual
of what you think
the person looks like,
but then it's
always kind of cool
to actually see what
they really look like.
So I'm gonna talk
about Seth Stewart,
the fellow that goes
around on Valentine's Day,
and gives roses to people.
The reason I picked him
is because, you know,
a few years ago on February
14th, Valentine's Day,
him and his buddies thought
to themselves, you know,
Valentine's Day is important
for people that have, you know,
a girlfriend or boyfriend
or significant other,
you know, they know that
they're gonna get something,
but what about Valentine's Day
for people who aren't expecting
a delivery at the door?
So what he wanted to do
was give roses to people
that don't have their
significant other,
or a loved one in their life.
So he prompted people
via social media
to nominate people
to get a rose.
And so he would go
to these, you know,
these residences where
there were widows,
or people who were having
a really tough time,
and so this became sort of,
you know, a movement, I guess.
And he was, every year,
it was getting bigger
and bigger and bigger.
And so when I talked to him,
he was such a wonderful guy.
I love chatting with him,
and he's just had this
great sense of humor,
and, you know, I
asked him, I'm like,
"So you have a girlfriend.
"How does she feel about this?
"You know, you go and
give roses to everybody."
And he said, "Well, you
know, she thinks it's great."
I said, "Well, of
course she does
"because you're doing
something important."
And his point was, "I'm not
giving roses to like, you know,
"women who I wanna date,
"I'm giving roses to people
who aren't expecting something,
"that they've had some
kind of loss in their life,
"or they have lost somebody,
"and maybe they're
not having a good day,
"and just a delivery of a rose
can change their outlook."
And you can, you
know, he sent me notes
that people wrote afterwards,
about how important
that one gesture was.
And then when I talked to Seth,
he told me something
about himself.
He too was diagnosed
with diabetes,
and he talked about his
struggle and how, at one point,
he got to the point where he
didn't wanna live anymore.
And he told me this story,
and it just, you know,
it made my heart break.
But the point was
is that he's so glad
that he wanted to stay alive
and do this for other people.
And how it's important that
when we go through challenges,
we realize that coming
out of those challenges,
we can be better people.
We can do things to
better ourselves,
be better human beings,
and so that just struck
me because I never
thought about him
telling me this
backstory to his life,
but it was important because
it kinda gives you an inside
to where this guy is coming
from, where his heart is.
And you know, his background
about how he really
truly wants to do good things
for other people to
change their day.
- Well, Janice, I think your
story is basically proof
that you're making
your own sunshine
in a year that was
pretty bizarre.
You are welcome back anytime,
especially if you
wanna talk about Cuomo,
and don't get me started
on this Newsome guy.
I'm on my own little
adventure with him.
So we're definitely in
this fight together.
So I thank you.
I hope I can see you in
Long Island sometime,
or you're always welcome
to come out here to L.A.
Megan knows my husband makes
a pretty good chicken parm.
- Can I tell you that I was
so jealous when she called me
about her evening, there
is no way she is going back
to L.A. without me in tow,
so that we can get together.
You guys are always
welcome to our home.
And I thank you,
this was a wonderful
interview, and, you know,
thank you for your
support and your kindness,
and you, my friend are
also spreading sunshine.
- There you go, all
right, thanks a lot.
- You're welcome.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists, all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.